shoulder to shoulder with one player at
the center of their thoughts the death
of 23 year old Cody Fisher has shaken
his Club to the Core
attending the team's first game since
his death his mother father and Uncle
have spoken for the first time
my life sentence started
it's cool and I got there and it was too
late she'd get there and not even make
it in time because he'd already died by
the time I'd got there there's there's
just no words
broken I can't even watch the game so
that's it
oh God so much no more we're so proud of
him my wife and my kids we are lost Cody
and we loved him to beats and I think
everyone felt the same way and um he's
just such a lovely lovely character and
a lovely kid and he'd be looking down
now and he'd be so happy and he'd be
proud
ahead of kickoff for God of Honor for
the players by children from St
Gregory's School Cody had trained many
of them and at 23 minutes past Cody's
age when he died the match paused
foreign
for players fans in the family to
celebrate his life
Cody was stabbed inside the crane
nightclub in Birmingham on boxing day
night while out with friends two men
aged 21 and 22 have been charged with
his murder with a trial due to begin in
July but for today it was a moment for a
club and a family to come together
I'm just so proud so so proud that he
was just an inspiration to so many
people
and you know my best friend that I've
lost so soon
and he was just just amazing he was just
an amazing amazing
child baby child lad as he grew you know
just just beyond words and Beyond cruel
I just I waved him off on boxing day the
pure Soul just just my absolute Angel to
have inspired so many people at such a
young age and the love for him is is for
me as as his mother is just the most
special it's just gonna be my comfort I
don't know how I got I'll go from here
how I get on from here like I say my
life sentence has started now
and you know it would never be easy
never ever ever ever
done Whitehead Sky News in Stratford
upon Avon